the Joe Rogan experience fun oh yeah he
has an iPhone too like literally iPhone
- he does it is it's the second
generation iPhone it's hilarious he
pulls it out of his pocket like what is
like like [ __ ] receipts and diner
matches I phone it tells all areas not
just hilarious as a comic but hilarious
is a human character he's one of my
favorites heat everyone so now I'll do
like a joke check and you'll get this
weird text from him that's like mmm hey
does anyone have anything about raccoons
and cats eating flags or something you
know it's like there's a combination of
like it's like a mad lib you're like no
I've I've not heard that one before I
just when you're a guy like him - if
you're writing joke jokes all the time
like everything's a joke joke yeah but
you never know if you heard that before
like you don't you're like your memory
only holds so much of course and and
he's like I mean his joke he is all
punchline yes that's all it is but a
bunch yeah it's great it's [ __ ] the
best but it is one of those things where
it's like yeah there's anyone have jokes
about like s'mores and it to me to me
he's the most underappreciated master of
our age yeah you know he's a like
legitimate master comedian and you know
he doesn't get the kind of love that he
should like from the general public
because he has zero marketing right zero
anything other than people saying he's
awesome and people seeing him be awesome
yeah you know and he's one of the rare
guys that got sober and got better he
really did and I also helped bring candy
to the club every once in a while which
I love candy I'm always happy they'll
just bring bags of candy to the cellar
every once in a while and I'm like I did
want a little baby Ruth yeah she's the
best everybody loves him like nobody
will tell you they hated tell ya I've
never heard that once he had this one
there's this one story of him doing
crowd work there was like a group of
like um latina women in the front and
mean-mugging the whole time just arms
crossed like every enough
we're talking about it you know like
after they're set they'd be like yeah
but then there's these women in the
front we couldn't break them at all
I tell gets onstage looks immediately at
them and when she goes he goes oh why so
sad did Selena die again oh my god
that's funny
but he has that like laser vision where
he can just he like sees it in the crowd
he has the perfect reference for it
holy [ __ ] that's funny oh my god that's
funny
it's David have to laugh at that you
have to you can't not oh my god that's
so funny did Selena die again holy [ __ ]
oh my god he's one of the greatest for
sure like legitimately one of the
greatest ever just doesn't get enough
credit but there's a lot of calm in that
in comedy right now to like I mean he's
been around for decades and should
definitely be like widely loved who else
um but like the other some of the
younger guys to it's like you know like
this Mark Norman's amarelle Dan Soder
just had special getting some it's just
like I feel like they're all
underappreciated you know like they're
guys that are like great joke writers
you know and it's like hard for them to
sell specials now cuz it's you know oh
people are like you're straight white
guy is that real I think it is yeah but
isn't like um I mean there are straight
white guys what's that that [ __ ] John
Mulaney he's straight white guy he has
characteristics hmm he does he he looks
nice he's presentable he has a small dog
you know but I'm pretty pretty dressed
as well yeah yeah stylish stylish very
good comic book I think he's an old
timey you know
[Applause]